vamos al problema 73 en el problema 73
nos preguntan cuánto costó una llamada
de teléfono costo queremos el costo de
la llamada de teléfono en el inciso 1 lo
que nos dicen es que la llamada duró 53
minutos 53 minutos por supuesto que esto
no nos dice nada del costo verdad pero a
lo mejor podemos juntarlo con el inciso
2 para para obtener información del
costo total bueno
el inciso 2 nos dice que el costo de los
primeros 3 minutos entonces le voy a
poner así costo primeros 3 minutos
minutos fue igual a 5 veces el costo de
cada minuto adicional 5 veces el costo
costo de cada minuto adicional adicional
muy bien aquí pues aquí tampoco tenemos
nada de información esto de aquí nada
más nos da una proporción entre el costo
de los primeros minutos y el costo
adicional pero no nos dice cuánto cuesta
por ejemplo el costo de los primeros
cinco minutos o tres minutos pudo haber
sido de 10 y en entonces el costo de
cada minuto adicional sería 2 sale o
bien aquí pudo haber sido 20 y aquí pudo
haber sido 4 y entonces esto cumple
satisface esto pero no o sea nos dan
costos diferentes entonces éste por sí
mismo tampoco nos dice nada y ni
siquiera juntando los verdad aunque
sepamos que los minutos adicionales son
50 pues no tenemos información para
determinar así concretamente cuál es el
costo entonces la respuesta sería eh
ni siquiera juntando las dos los dos
pedazos de información podemos responder
y de hecho el segundo es un poco ambiguo
porque no se entiende si el costo de los
primeros tres minutos es de cada uno de
ellos o en conjunto pero de cualquier
forma no podemos determinar el costo
vale bueno vamos ahora a la pregunta 74
pregunta 74 efe está bien larga dice en
una cierta oficina el 50% de los
empleados tienen licenciatura entonces
el 50% de los empleados tienen
licenciatura le voy a poner así 50% de
los empleados es igual a la cantidad de
empleados con licenciatura ok
luego nos dice que el 60% de los
empleados tiene 40 años o más
entonces el 60%
de los empleados tiene 40 años o más le
voy a poner así se vale y también nos
dice que el 30 por ciento de los que
tienen 40 años o más tienen maestría ok
entonces le voy a poner así el 30 por
ciento de los que tienen 40 años o más
son los que tienen maestría muy bien
entonces la pregunta es cuántos
empleados que tienen 40 años o más
tienen maestría entonces queremos
determinar el valor de m cuál es el
valor de m bueno vamos a ver qué
opciones nos dan en el inciso 1 nos
dicen que exactamente 100 de los
empleados tienen licenciatura entonces
nos están diciendo que él es igual a 100
ok entonces si sabemos que él es igual a
100 y que el 50% de los empleados
totales es él o sea 100 de aquí podemos
juntar esta con esta y obtener que los
empleados es igual a 200
luego podemos juntar mira aquí juntamos
está con esta luego podemos juntar esta
con esta y nos dice que el 60% de 200cc
o sea que se es igual a 120 y finalmente
podemos juntar esta con esta sale esta
con esta y tenemos que m es el 30% de
120 es decir 36 36
entonces el inciso 1 es suficiente para
encontrar el valor de m vamos a ver qué
dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos dice
que de los empleados de 40 años o menos
25% tienen maestría pero esto ya no
tiene nada que ver con los que tienen 40
años o más
entonces si tienen 40 años o menos y
sabemos que tienen maestría pues
realmente no nos importan entonces este
de acá nos sirve para determinar el
valor de m vale entonces la respuesta
sería ar
muy bien vamos ahora el problema 75 en
el problema 75 en el 75 lo que nos piden
es determinar si r s t si este producto
es igual a 1 bueno pues vamos a ver qué
opciones nos dan
en el inciso 1 nos dicen que ese es
igual a 1 si sabemos que r es igual a 1
pues sólo sabemos que este cachito es
igual a 1 y te podría hacer lo que sea
entonces no podemos determinar si se da
esta igualdad este por sí mismo no es
suficiente y en el 2 nos dicen que ese
tema es igual a 1 misma idea esta
información por sí misma pues le da
mucha libertad a r entonces no sabemos
nada acerca de esto qué sucede si
combinamos estas dos pues yo digo que
aunque las combinamos o sea aunque
sepamos que las dos se cumplen no
podemos determinar si el 7 es igual a 1
por ejemplo puede ser que sea igual a
ese que sea igual a t que sea igual a 1
que sea igual a 1 y entonces en efecto
se cumplen estas dos y el producto es
igual a 1 pero también nos podría pasar
que r fuera igual a 6 que esté fuera
igual a un sexto y que te fuera igual a
6 y entonces se cumple que eres 1st es 1
pero rst es igual a 6 entonces tenemos
tenemos dos casos que satisfacen esto
pero que nos dan respuestas distintas
aquí arriba y por lo tanto ni siquiera
juntando a ambos
ambos pedazos de información podemos
responder esta pregunta entonces la
respuesta sería
muy bien y finalmente en este vídeo creo
que me da tiempo de hacer uno más vamos
a hacer el 76 el 76 lo voy a poner en
este color rosa y viene un dibujo el
dibujo es un diagrama un diagrama
circular entonces tenemos más o menos
algo así
deja de intentar hacer que me quede lo
más parecido posible a lo del examen
tenemos algo de este estilo luego va a
cada más o menos este va para acá
este va para acá ok y las regiones
tienen ciertos nombres esta región se
llama r aquí está marcado un ángulo de
equis grados esta se llama s ésta se
llama t
esta se llama p y esta se llama cu ok es
pq rs y está muy bien tenemos este
diagrama de aquí y está etiquetado como
los gastos de las cinco divisiones de la
compañía h muy bien entonces este es el
gas estoy aquí es gastos
de 5 divisiones divisiones de la
compañía h muy bien vamos a ver qué dice
el problema el problema dice la figura
representa una gráfica circular de los
gastos de la compañía h partidos en cada
una de sus cinco divisiones ok puede ser
como como publicidad producción bueno
etcétera no va nos dice si o es el
centro de la circunferencia aquí este se
llama o si yo es el centro de la
circunferencia o del círculo y la y la
compañía h en total gasto 5 millones 400
mil dólares me voy a poner el total
el total fue 5.4 millones de dólares ok
entonces la pregunta es cuáles fueron
los gastos para la división r
entonces como estoy aquí es un diagrama
circular básicamente necesitamos saber
qué parte es este cachito de aquí de
todo el círculo entonces necesitamos
saber pues esta x cuánto vale si sabemos
cuántos grados son entonces podemos
saber la proporción de esos grados a 360
y entonces la proporción de r a todo
vale bueno entonces en el inciso 1 lo
que nos dicen es pues justo nos dicen
que x que x es igual a 94-94 muy bien
esto de aquí es información suficiente
porque entonces tenemos que r entre el
total
entre 5.4 millones es igual a 94 entre
360 y de aquí podemos obtener el valor
de r es re sería igual a 94 entre 360 y
multiplicamos por el total o sea 5.4
millones esta operación la podemos
resolver no lo vamos a hacer porque no
es el chiste del game at vale lo
importante es que esta información fue
suficiente y en el inciso 2 lo que nos
dice es que el gasto total de las
divisiones aceite aceite es igual al
doble de los gastos de r
entonces ese máster es igual a 2 r sale
pero eso no nos nos permite determinar
el valor de cr que es lo que queremos
conocer porque porque pues no se déjame
marcar aquí en el dibujo que tenemos
tendríamos que esta región de acá ese
máster es igual simplemente al doble de
r pero a lo mejor es más 34 y eres 2 y
aquí se reparte todo lo demás o bien ese
máster es 22 dólares y eres igual a 1 y
aquí se reparte lo demás o bueno estoy
aquí podrían ser muchos millones a lo
mejor esto estos son dos millones y esto
es un millón y aquí se reparte los demás
vayan simplemente saber la información
del inciso 2 no nos permite concluir
cuál es el valor de r porque hay muchas
posibilidades entonces aquí la respuesta
sería a
y eso quiere decir que el inciso 1 sirve
pero el inciso 2 es inútil